there's a seat in the middle girl i've
already lost two
i'm missing we used to call bobby
blacktooth did he tell you that oh
did you just kill the black tooth no
yeah i'll make a sticker
what bobby king blacktooth bobby we used
to call him king blacktooth
because all of his teeth in the back
were black holes well
he chews how does he eat his food three
teeth he no longer has those
teeth good they have sins perished no i
think it's like it's definitely
like a i mean he did a lot of drugs too
i've lost two t's bobby three tooth yeah
that's his mafia name
when he when he eats it's hard to watch
him right he goes
well no here's the thing you do learn to
gum it i'm not gonna lie
i'm missing oh you just stick you just
grapes in between those two
missing teeth you just have to practice
right but his thing is like he always
wants to go to steakhouses
and he always orders steaks and he has
to swallow it whole because he can't
chew it so he takes these big chunks and
he's just like you just see that big
piece just
go down his neck i i hate that [ __ ]
smell you don't like it yeah i hate that
it's funky it's like a sock i have to
admit that durian was easier for me than
the balloon yeah really
it was very well it's just egg to me i
don't think they were either they
weren't neither one of them
they were both delicious i heard about
dorian a lot but it's something
yeah we didn't get a stinky one it did
smell a little funky
i'm really proud of you guys it can you
can't really
describe the smell it smells really
specific
yeah yeah um sulfur can bob get like
dentures implants can you can he just
get fake teeth in there yeah i mean he's
got money i don't
know what is who has money he sure has
very little teeth why don't you just do
that
but he doesn't like the dentist right
yeah but he likes food
he likes food but if you don't it's
that's implants are hard it's painful
yeah it is it's painful
painful oh my god have you have you had
them no i won't get them i'm missing two
teeth but i won't get them because it's
too they stick a
a rod up there oh there's like a rod in
your gums they don't they don't fist it
um
and then they have you have to wait a
while for it to heal before you put the
actual implant
on there i screw a rod and it pulls your
tooth in so most people don't want to do
that
especially if you don't see it we did it
we did it do we have any helpful advice
this week guild
we do we have a question on hopeful
advice
i love your shoes so yeah you like them
yeah and stevie
weaves is it el nino no la this is like
the nike of china
lightning oh yeah so good
really yeah so good can you get me a
pair yeah i mean they're on uh there's a
store on fairfax
is that dwyane wade's shoe no yeah he's
how do you know he's sponsored by
every nba player now has a shoe in china
yeah he's he's their premier player
dwayne wade's um
um sponsored by lining oh well this
yeah a chinese company oh
god all right guys absolutely here's the
unhelpful question
feel free to give helpful advice very
hard or unhelpful advice steve here we
go